cette situation humanitaire très
inquiétante en afghanistan depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans
l'économie est quasiment paralysée
conséquence les conditions de vie des
afghans se dégrader très rapidement au
point qu'un million de personnes est
menacée par la famine notre envoyé
spécial antoine gayraud est à kaboul
l'économie afghane est en chute libre
plus d'un afghan sur deux est sans
emploi télé le bilan peu reluisant que
l'on peut faire du pays à l'heure
actuelle les ong tentent vient d'avertir
la communauté internationale de la
catastrophe humanitaire qui se profile
ces mêmes ong qui sont déjà très active
sur le terrain nous avons passé la
journée d'hier sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de kaboul et nous avons pu
observer plusieurs allers-retours
plusieurs atterrissages et décollages
d'appareils de l'onu ou encore de
médecins sans frontières et c'est dans
ce contexte que la russie a fourni une
aide humanitaire de 36 tonnes à
l'afghanistan une aide humanitaire plus
que bienvenus
oui c'est extrêmement important car
aujourd'hui l'afghanistan est au bord
d'une crise humanitaire comme le rat
bornes de nombreuses agences de presse
et les agences de l'onu un actionnaire s
[Musique]
en fait c'est à cause des conflits et du
changement récent de gouvernement en
afghanistan aujourd'hui les afghans sont
confrontés à de nombreux défis à de
nombreux problèmes dans différents
domaines de leur vie c'est pourquoi nous
avons vraiment besoin d'une aide
humanitaire d'une coopération avec les
pays amis du monde entier
pour
les ong craignent en plus que l'hiver
qui se profile soit particulièrement
difficile en effet le pays a connu cette
année une grave sécheresse autant de
facteurs qui font que les plus faibles
n'en sont que plus vulnérables
j'assume tout faux
vous savez nous nous attendons à un
hiver froid qui arrivera dans quelques
mois et cela affectera beaucoup de
personnes vulnérables principalement les
enfants et les femmes qui rencontreront
différents types de problèmes
foot
par conséquent premier lieu la
nourriture et l'assistance médicale sont
très importantes pour nous et dans un
second temps des abris et des vêtements
pour que les gens n'aient pas froid
pendant l'hiver un
winter
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans
leur gouvernement n'a pas été reconnue à
l'international et des sanctions
économiques ont été adoptées contre le
pays des sanctions qui pèsent sur les
finances du pays et qui ne seront levés
que lorsque le gouvernement fournira
dégage des garanties concernant les
droits humains et les droits de la femme